درجات الحراره متدنيه والعمل مازال جاريا
في هذه المواقع هنا في مدينه اضنه مواقع
انهيار الابنيه هذه الاليات الثقيله هي
تحاول ازاله القطع الكبيره والركام
الموجود هناك في تلك النقطه حاولنا الوصول
اليها بالكاميرا ما زال عمال الانقاذ
يحاولون الوصول هنا نرى بعض الاشياء التي
تم اخراجها من المبنى وهناك محاوله لازاله
القطع الكبيره كما تحدثنا في تلك النقطه
تماما هناك محاوله مكثفه من اجل الوصول
الى احد الاشخاص لكن الى الان ليس واضحا
ما اذا كان هذا الشخص
على قيد الحياه ام لا ولكن الجهود هي
مستمره فرق الانقاذ المتطوعون الجميع هو
يحاول مسابقه الزمن من اجل ان يتم الوصول
الى الاشخاص الذين هم موجودون تحت الابنيه
نلاحظ هناك عمال من البلديه والشرطه وكل
هؤلاء هم يحاولون تقسيم العمل بينهم من
اجل استمراريه هذا العمل هناك في تلك
النقطه مثلا نجد سياره لاداره الطوارئ
والكوارث في تلك النقطه هناك خلف هؤلاء
الاشخاص هناك
عربه تقدم الشوربه الساخنه الطعام الساخن
للمحتاجين هناك خيمه صحيه في تلك المنطقه
هناك باللون الاحمر خيمه صحيه هناك اهتمام
من الصحافه العالميه بهذه
الكارثه الجميع يحاول نقل اخبار هذه
الكارثه خصوصا وان هذا الزلزال هو ربما
الزلزال الاكبر في تاريخ الجمهوريه
التركيه منذ تاسيسها منذ حوالي ثلاثينيات
القرن الماضي وبالتالي نحن امام كارثه
حقيقيه وما زالت اعمال الانقاذ واعمال
ازاله الركام مستمره هذا الوضع في اضنه
والتي هي ربما اقل من غيرها من المدن
الاخرى فما بالك
بالاوضاع في المناطق والمدن الاخرى